hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast validating and publishing with
antibodies how to avoid reviewers
challenges presented by dr. Chandra
Mohan a senior manager and scientific
content training at Milla Poor's Sigma
I'm dr. Susie Valdes of lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
routes and sponsored by Milla poor Sigma
for more information about our sponsor
visit them at WWE MD Milla poor calm
before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type the questions into
the drop-down box that appear on the
screen our speaker will respond to your
questions via email if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on that ask a
question box and let us know you're
having a problem this participation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits just click on the
continuing education credits tab located
on the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process for obtaining those credits
please join me now in welcoming our
speaker dr. Chandra Mohan I will now
turn the presentation over to him
welcome dr. Mohan
thank you Susie welcome to Millie Poor's
Sigma's virtual seminar today's topic is
validating and publishing with
antibodies and how to in avoid reviewers
challenge you might be working for six
months to a year to get publishable data
you prepare the manuscript with great
diligence submit and wait for a letter
of acceptance and sometimes it comes
back with minus revisions and at other
times it is rejected which is very
disappointing so today we will talk
about a few simple steps that you can
take to improve your chances of
acceptance
of your manuscript
before I commence with the main topic I
would like to bring your attention to
the fact that Milly poor and Sigma are
now one company and Sigma was acquired
by Merck KGaA from Germany in 2016
that's our parent company and as a
combined organization we carry over 300
thousand products including about 90,000
antibodies we are in 77 different
countries and we have 72 different
manufacturing sites throughout the world
validation of antibodies is a big
question and also a big question is why
do we need antibodies in biological
research over the past two decades you
have notice there researchers for safety
and regulatory reasons have shifted from
radioactive techniques to more immuno
techniques and as immuno techniques are
improved and modified more and more
people are adopting these techniques why
do we use antibodies because we want to
identify a target molecule which is
important for us we want to locate the
target molecule within this cell whether
it's mitochondria where this nucleus or
endoplasmic reticulum we want to see
where it is located and sometimes we can
use these antigen molecules as cell or
tissue type markers they some of them
will be specific only for one particular
tissues
some of them will tell us the
physiological stage or the disease state
of a tissue those are some of the
important things the target molecule can
also be it can also be used for
purification concentration of further
analysis by help of antibodies so when
you are doing this kind of work and
you're publishing a reviewer can always
ask you a question the marker you have
chosen is not exclusively found in that
cell that cell type and that will be a
question for you to answer to the
reviewers so our response will be don't
be - target proteins
focused take for example gaba vs gaba
transporters they are they present in
the same cell many different markers may
exit for a particular type of tissue now
you can use at least two different
markers for the same tissue to support
your hypothesis sometimes they stay in
see use for the histochemical work may
be self specific nowadays more and more
people are also using mrnas messenger
rna's are micro rna's which can support
your publication to show to the viewers
that you have already checked these
things and your choice of antibody
Archer is good now first of all we have
to see why antibody antibodies have high
binding specificity there and this
specificity can be used to identify
isolate immunoprecipitate even in rich
samples so that's why we use antibodies
in multiple applications
now it's not as easy as said that
antibody specificity is the one which
you should use and all your experiments
will be good it can really antibody
specificity does not mean it is very
reliable unless you take precautions
antibody specifically can be affected by
multiple factors such as the
concentration of the antibody use was
the buffer system use is the pH altered
is the presence of any detergents which
can affect the performance how was the
animal immunized when did we collect the
blood if you collect the blood at early
phase the title will be very low they
may not be enough antibodies then if you
collect in the middle phase maybe after
two months after injection the antibody
titer will be very high and to a detail
and maybe six or seven months later if
you go and collect your sample the again
the antibody concentration could be low
so those are the factors which can
affect your choice of antibody as well
as the performance of your experiments
so a review can always ask a question
can make a comment the buffers chosen to
dilute your antibody has detergents
which is known to affect the HRP there's
horseradish peroxidase and dab which is
diamino benzene in reaction how do you
respond to something like that now this
is a common question they can ask but
you know you have to know and justify
these steps in your protocol it's not
always that one protocol which you
obtain either from a textbook or from a
publication or from a vendor is the one
here to use it's not one-size-fits-all
protocol you must end up the protocol to
your experiments I adopt the protocol to
what kind of detergents what kind of
reaction buffers you have so every
antibody is different so the you have to
optimize each antibody and sometimes
with each different lot you have to do
that because title may be different with
different Lots
now antibody choice can also depend on
your application what type of tissue
sample you're using what type of cells
are the cell lysate or tissue homogenate
you're using so always have the target
into your mind target consideration is
important where is your target located
in this cell is it in the nucleus is it
in the cell membrane then the processing
of the tissue will be different what
type of sample is to be used also sample
preparation how do you prepare this
sample to keep the antigen in tact if
you use very harsh treatment antigen may
be destroyed if you use homogenous Asian
techniques or cell lysis technique some
of the nonspecific proteases may come
into play and they may destroy your
small amount of antigen so what
precautions you have to take those are
some of the things which are important
in antibody choice antibody design
consideration is important to what is
what's the purpose here we want to see
whether a monoclonal antibody is better
suited for us your experiment or is a
polyclonal antibodies that is better
suited for your experiment what's the
epitope sequence is the epitope sequence
totally buried inside in a tertiary
structure the conformational change has
to be brought about those are some of
the things in the antibody design you
have to take into account now again the
target antigen consideration affects the
assay design take for example with our
antibodies which are used in small
amounts you have to design your
experiment well you have to plan ahead
ask questions ask questions from
suppliers and the vendors who are
providing you antibodies colleagues who
have used these antibodies in their work
so some of those things are important
it's important to know where the target
is is an internal target is external
target is a transmembrane that means you
have to use certain detergents to bring
that antigen out of the membrane how do
you do that do we have to use protease
inhibitors they are to use protein
protein phosphatase or a protein kinase
inhibitor in your experiment to maintain
the phosphorylation state of your
antigen
these are some of the important
considerations which you have to take
into account when you are designing your
experiments sometimes the structure of
the molecule structure of your antigen
can be important on how do you bring it
out so the epitope is exposed where the
antibody is going to react with that
are built into development of quality
and should be evaluated prior to
antibodies use so when even before you
buy the antibody you should take these
things into consideration on the right
side you see a small book here which I'm
going to put a little bigger image in
the next slide it's called an
introduction to antibodies and their
applications it's about a hundred page
book and we have published this a couple
of years back in 2015 is we wrote this
book it's about one hundred page book
that provide details knowledge about
antibody use theory of antibody etc what
are the precautions technical tips much
information is there this is excellent
reference source for any lab at the end
of the presentation I'm going to provide
you my email number email address and
you can request a copy we provide this
free of charge to any researchers just
ask for it and this will be highly
useful in your lab now this book has a
lot of information it has theory of
antigen-antibody reaction a lot of
protocols are provided troubleshooting
guides technical tips a lot of watch
outs are there that what not to do how
to avoid certain pitfalls in the
experiment these are the kind of
information which is included in this
book which you will find it very useful
in addition we also have sample
protocols sample protocols for Eliza
Western blotting immunohistochemistry
immunofluorescence etc and we have many
tips and tricks
and we also have a glossary of commonly
used terms and that will be really
useful for newcomers in the field of you
know biology now it's important to know
what sample you are going to be testing
so even before you purchase an antibody
this is the important consideration some
proteins are expressed only in certain
selected cells our tissues and so if you
are using an antibody let's say you use
a protein kinase antibody will it react
with particular tissue
take for example protein kinase C gamma
isoform is present only in brain and
nowhere else so you have to be careful
on what you use if you use PK C gamma on
some other tissue is not going to give
you a reactivity
so nature of the target protein and
location of the target protein is
important and the publishers usually
doesn't ask because they know we're
better use the right material are not
but you should provide sufficient data
either your own data are published data
to show that that the target protein is
being expressed in your tissue ourselves
so this is important now also it's
important that expression levels can
change expression levels change usually
depending upon this is logical state of
the tissues or depending upon the
disease state of the tissue the levels
of the antigen can change so that you
should keep in mind if there is a very
low expression how much antibody to use
if there is a high expression protein in
this tissue or in the cells then you can
even dilute the antibody a little bit so
that you get more reliable results
sometimes what happens is proteins may
be short-lived
or they may be very labile and how do
you study that that's the important
thing
so take for example those who are
studying the a protic cell depth they
know that after induction of apoptosis
whole process is over within a few
minutes twenty to thirty minutes the
whole thing is over and sometimes you
may not be able to detect the endpoint
so it's important to design an
experiment in a way where you can detect
your results properly result the target
is detected at the end in a very nice
way the other important thing is the
target consideration as I mentioned
sometimes the epitope may be on the pre
or pro protein region so then if the pro
region are the protein a pro region or
the pre region has been eliminated
during the activation of the protein
activation of the enzyme particular I
take for example pro cat obscene if the
epitope is on the pro region and then
you are using an antibody which reacts
with that particular epitope once the
enzyme is activated you may not get a
reaction it will be a negative effect
there so those are important sometimes
is the latent are the activated proteins
are detected take for example some
antibodies are specific only to the
phosphorylated form are only to the non
phosphorylated form or other protein
translational modification acetylation
ubiquitination simulation those are the
other things you have to take into
account when you are designing your
experiment registry structures can
obscure target so when you are
denaturing or degrading protocols will
be needed in that so there are multiple
things here to test in there if you are
using live cells then it's recommended
that you use an antibody which is not
preserved in a site solution so those
are some of these things important if it
is the intracellular or intra membrane
locking
how do you bring them out what cannot
detergent here to use it has to be very
mild attention which does not destroy
your antigen so those are some of the
considerations you have to take into
account now the review can always ask
can you submit data showing that the
antibody you use is very specific
so take for example here we using tri
methyl lysine 27 site so do you if you
are using histone antibodies and then
you are using one very specific for one
particular modification site here it is
tri methylated lysine on site 27 huh how
do you show that to the reviewer that
you are right so state dependent
antibodies must have extensive
validation how do you do that I am going
to show you some of those first of all
when you buy that antibody you go to the
vendor website when the datasheet they
should provide you the validation data
protocols and control samples are often
available from vendors are from your own
lab and so yes
it is not available you should use your
own control data these are important
things here take for example we do one
protocol which is called at the antibody
app surance our abstinence method for
testing shows very high specificity
our-our histone antibodies take for
example his tri methyl lysine 4 on
histone h3 so h3k4me3 that will be read
try methylated lysine on histone h3 the
lysine is at position 4 how do you show
that so when we do these kind of
experiments when they do the abstinence
kind of experiments you will see that
only on the boxes 2 green boxes there
you will see the reaction just two boxes
are 4 10 nano gram and 100 nano gram and
you will see that all the other boxes
are empty it does not react with
k3i h3k4 it does not react with the mono
methylated it does not react with the
dye methylated it reacts only with the
tri methylated form so this is the
excellence of validation so we are not
saying that we test all antibody this
way but some of them where it is very
critical particularly with this
modification site we do test our
antibodies this way it's highly specific
binding to the tri methyl lysine try
methylate lysine on his own life in for
on histone h3 now sometimes what happens
is
of probation is not adequate it's
usually overlooked process a lot of
people don't pay detailed attention to
how you're making your sample how do you
are making your life Seder how you are
doing your homogenate without damaging
the antigen these are important things
sometimes the antigen is present in very
small amounts it's low abundance how do
you do that in that case you can always
isolate the organelles take for example
your material is present only in the
nucleus are in only in the mitochondria
then you do fractionation and we have
various different kits available which
you see in the last column here so this
will cause the enrichment of the
organelles and then you can have a
better reaction you can have adequate
signal generated sometimes a target is
too small it's a small peptide of a much
larger protein in that case you use the
size exclusion filtration you can see on
the last column we have provided a
Mekong ultra side exclusion spin filters
and sometimes it's obscured in the
plasma membrane are in another
organelles inside the cell in that case
we have what is we call it totally
extract kits and then a particular type
of fraction can be collected and
analyzed and if the signal is very weak
because the binding is weak then you can
use some of these other things like
subcellular fractionation you can use
you can reach a concentration of
proteins and we have the concentration
systems available so these are some of
the tricks you can follow on techniques
you can apply now before you begin to
plan your experiment check if what kind
of antibodies will be best suited for
your experiments whether it is a
monoclonal antibodies or whether it's a
polyclonal antibody if it's a large
antigen it will have multiple epitopes
in that case if polyclonal antibody may
be better suited for the reaction if it
is a small antigen and has fewer
epitopes of only one epitope then
chances of better reactivity comes with
the monoclonal
so those are some of the things we have
to take into consideration when you're
doing these experiments now there's a
big controversy on our discussion on
whether to use monoclonal or poly cross
the poly clones have certain advantages
and mono claws have certain advantages
take for example poly kronos they are
easy to make they give you a better
signal there are multiple epitopes there
are more applications and they are
better suited for denatured proteins
whereas disadvantage is what happens if
the animal died then you'd have no
source of animal producing antibody and
that if you inject a new animal it may
take a few months to get that lot to lot
variations because if you bleed the
animal at certain time and then two
months later you'll have a variation in
the lots different bleeds will give
different results and sometimes you can
have nonspecific binding so Maui my
recommendation and our recommendation is
you plan your experiment well assess
your antibody needs order more than one
while at a time so that you can avoid
lot to lot variation in the antibody now
same thing happens in monoclonal
actually the reviewers comments on the
poly Chloe they repeat your experiment
with the mono play to be confident of
your polychrome so it's not a bad idea
but not necessary you can always choose
a polyclonal made from a shorter peptide
instead of the whole molecule take a
short peptide which is specific only for
that antigen and then you can also do
multi application so you can do Western
plot and amino history chemistry of
Western blot and flow cytometry in the
same experiment if T antibody works in
those applications so at least do two
applications so that gives confidence in
your own data and reviewers like that
now the monoclonal antibodies have
certain advantages they have high
specificity they have less best to batch
variation they bind only to one antigen
and the hybridomas can be maintained and
you have the indefinite infinite source
of antibody but the disadvantage could
be their labor intensive they're more
expensive they are limited applications
and they may not work in all species
and sometimes the epitope could be
affected by chemical treatments so those
are some of the disadvantages so you
have to make that decision before you
start your experiments so sometimes the
reviewer can ask the error bars are the
standard deviations are disturbingly
large on your allies our data how do you
answer that question
so one thing you do is your lockdown
your protocol and you can order all your
antibodies from the same vendors from
the same lot and you can confirm with
mono confirm your experiment using a
monoclonal antibody by increasing
replicates so instead of doing one
experiment to experiment just do maybe
four or five repeats of that so it may
give you statistically better results
now antibody validation is necessary but
not very well defined so why worry about
validation now a couple of years back
2014 to be precise Amgen scientists
started working on some 54 different
targets based on the publication's and
they wanted to repeat this experiment to
take it further so that they can do some
drug development studies and what they
found was out of 54 they could 50 out of
53 they could repeat only six
that's like 11% success so there was a
big issue raised that why they could not
repeat this in the even in the
industrial settings so multiple
publications from academia and industry
have raised this issue of
reproducibility there is the specificity
of antibodies and so based on that many
different publications came out and some
of them were from industry and some of
them were from academic labs questioning
the specificity and reproducibility of
antibodies even our own company we have
published two different publications
here what you see on the top light blue
evolving strategies and applications and
further consideration of antibody
validation we are we bring out some of
these issues with antibodies now based
on
a lot of recommendations have been made
it's like multiple approaches to improve
reproducibility are being explored they
are even talking about establishment of
a data base housing unique antibody IDs
and their development information is
something like a central library of
clones something like you have for the
cells with the ATCC the funding agencies
and publishers should ask for more
details on the development and
validation of antibodies
we should be able to provide more
trainings for the users of antibodies
and the interpretation of those data and
that's why we load that book on the
antibodies introduction to antibodies
and it's biological applications
so the improvements in validation has to
be done by the developers of antibody
whether it's you're getting that
antibody from a vendor commercial vendor
or a friend or a different lab you
should be able to validate that antibody
before putting those into your
experiment now I'm not going to go into
these details slide what it shows is
whose job it is to validate antibodies
ultimately of course you are the one who
is publishing it so your job is also to
make sure that the antibody used is
proper and as supplier of antibodies the
commercial sources are supposed to be
responsible to make sure that they
provide you with a good product which
works in all your experiments are at
least in the tissue samples are into the
applications display a design for so
this is an important thing now a couple
of years back designs Mac's in delay
webinar series and what they did was
they talk about the
and accuracy so how do you demonstrate
precision and accuracy is like a target
if your demos if it is a sensitive issue
it's a sensitivity issue thus
appreciation reproducibility is also
appreciation specificity means it reacts
only with one particular epitope or one
particular antigen that's accuracy you
should be able to repeat that it should
be application specific so if you say it
works in immunohistochemistry it should
work in that that's also accuracy so it
should be sensitive it should be
reproducible it should exhibit
specificity for the antigen and it
should give you specificity in that
particular application those are the
things discussing that so a reviewer can
ask you I am not convinced of your
antibody specificity they are not
convinced of this specificity the
antibody how did to convince them use
two or more different techniques to
verify specificity maybe say Western
blot and amino extra chemistry or amino
site of chemistry and and Eliza use two
or more antibodies to different
immunogen's of regions for the same
antigen test again state dependent
controls including knockouts which we
are going to talk about little later so
use of knockout X models are becoming
more and more popular now so we do at
least two different type of testing at
ours at Milly for Sigma we do at least
two types of testing to validate our
antibody sometimes even more than two
testings are done on the antibodies so a
reviewers comment could be antibody
failed in Western blotting but seems to
work in immunohistochemistry that means
the antibody appears to be of low
quality how do we overcome that it is
not uncommon to have antibodies which
work in one application but not in
others is common especially in mongrels
check with the vendor even before you
buy the antibody check when they've been
drew if there is any particular
protocols you have to follow the epitope
maybe block in that application
confirm using different antibodies
against the same target are two
different epitopes on the same target
those will be some of the consideration
and once you include that data it's not
that you have to provide all data in the
same publication sometimes you can send
supplementary data to the editors which
they will be passing on to the reviewers
so those are some other things need to
take into consideration
now antibody
and as a validation is part of a good
experimental design so there are
multiple things you can do depending
upon the target and depending upon the
antibody is like a peptide inhibition
asses are done micro arrays are done
multiple application validations are
done and you know take for example here
Western blotting and flow cytometry at
least two different kind of testing is
done on validation you are always used
controls so those are some of the good
experimental habits which you can use at
Milly for Sigma what we do is for all
our new antibodies which for last
several years now we have been doing
testing in at least two most relevant
applications to the target it could be
Western blotting immuno precipitation
immunohistochemistry flow cytometry
sometimes chromatin immunoprecipitation
as the case may be we also purify our
antibodies in a variant robust way we
want to ensure the specificity and lack
of any cross reactivity of antibodies so
those are some of the things which we do
at Milly for Sigma take for example some
of our validation include enhanced
validation we call it Eevee is all
enhanced validation now here in this
particular case take for example we have
treated samples with kinase specific
activators or inhibitors to verify
specificity
phosphatase treatment to remove that
phosphate group so the reaction does not
come in sometimes the blocking
experiments are done with antigen
peptide to eliminate all signals
sometimes dot blots are done to confirm
specificity
and we also check for the correct
subcellular localization
are by following a certain treatment if
the molecule moves from one location to
the other within the cell those kind of
things can be verified in addition to
that what we have been doing is for some
of our antibodies we do the genetic
validation with RNA IRSA RNA knockdown
the CRISPR gasps nine techniques are
highly used for gene editing and
creating knockouts we can compare data
from wild-type and gene knockout cells
sometimes gene function can be
suppressed that way so here take for
example we are getting a reaction by the
using the anti a TRX here Western blot
it gives you one band single band
whereas at two different concentration
when you using the SI RNA we don't get a
reaction that means they blocked so now
this shows the specificity of the
antibody in addition to that sometimes
what we do is we do what is called as
orthogonal validation here we compare
the email article techniques with the
level of mRNA using RNA sequence
protocols expression of mRNA correlates
very well with the protein expression
levels now here on the left we have the
Western blot for the antibody to women
it in anti VM and on the right side we
have the mRNA expression so here is the
PLA
to our one expression we whether we see
the expression it correlates well with
the mRNA level also additionally we also
use multiple antibodies against the same
target to confirm protein present in
that particular sample type so these are
some of the important considerations for
you to know when we are picking
antibodies when you're buying antibody
from a particular vendor you should have
proper control data you can have a
positive result but where is the
negative result some tissues may not
express our sometimes you have a
negative staining how do you do those
you check for the vendor's data if we
are not provided you have to do it your
own what type of controls we do lot to
lot variation how do we avoid that it is
important to note that any validation
cell have good controls for example if
you are doing immunohistochemistry we
should show both positive and negative
staining when you check vendor data
sheet always check for the controls how
robust is the data these are some of the
important things you have to keep in
mind the type of controls could be
positive control negative control
sometimes the ISO type controls state
specific control whether it is a
phosphorylation acetylation and
application-specific reagent controls
whether the signal is being produced or
not produced because of certain things
present in this experiment either then
we do test with no primary antibodies no
secondary antibody different
applications we test it so those are
some of the important things and also
one important thing is when you compare
antibodies check vendor data price is
the last thing you want to check you
want get quality materials and most of
these antibodies vendors are pretty
competitive in pricing but quality is
this something which you have to always
check check to see what type of sample
was tested was it tested on cell lysate
or tissue homogenate all our particular
type of cell line that's a good data
sometimes the data by vendor is
generated only by using a purified
protein a recombinant protein and this
is supposed to give you result
but is that something which you can use
are you trust that in real live
conditions where you're using cell
lysate satisha homogenates other thing
you want to check is see if a
verification of the presence of antigen
is provided by Eliza or whether there is
more in-depth data like immuno Saito
chemistry flow cytometry
immunohistochemistry etc are done so
those specific application that are
become very important in your decision
making process also cross application
validation is important because that
gives the indication on how robust the
antigen-antibody reaction is if you get
very weak reaction in one and very
strong reaction in other okay you can
live with that but if you get very weak
reaction in everything else then your
tool really makes a decision whether you
can use that antibody or not
now when the data is important take for
example here is a typical example I
would say that I'm not claiming that all
our data sheets look like this but most
of them look like this a lot of testing
goes behind edge antibody that we
produce here we have data on western
blotting immunohistochemistry no site or
chemistry flow cytometry immuno
precipitation so some of the antibodies
are tested in multiple application not
that all antibodies are valid in each
application some of them will work only
in certain applications but if they work
in as many application as possible we
try to provide that data to our
customers now other important thing is
the
what you do when you submit your
manuscript careful experimental design
is important and that can eliminate a
lot of reviewers concern determine the
best application for your research need
what type of sample is being tested
what is the immunogen species and design
and at the end of course if you want
good technical support from a company
don't forget technical service sometimes
you need help in the middle of your
experiments so a live help in this area
will be very valuable now some of the
major concerns from the reviewers
our incomplete information provided so
if you want reviewers to speed up the
process you should always provide
complete name of the antibody species of
the emulator and whether there is a
human mouse rat zebrafish which our
species the antigen was derived you
should know that and in you know that
but you not put in the manuscripts a
reviewer does not know that antigen used
to raise antibody what was the dilution
used any references you have for the
validation if it is a monoclonal
antibody always include a clone number
if you are providing a catalog number
and a lot number for the antibody that's
a plus point for the reviewers and now
you are ready for publications this
publication is a peer-reviewed journal
it involves a complex process it
involves reviews very critical reviews
by people who are very knowledgeable in
that area you can make your reviewers
and editors life easy remember if you
are spend at least one to two hours
reviewing your manuscript and they don't
get paid for it they are doing just in
the name of science the golden rule will
be respond completely respond politely
even if the comments are ok you have to
repeat these experiments don't think
that you are not going to do it because
review is very knowledgeable they have
reviewed a lot of papers they reviewed a
lot of publications and this publication
is going to be a permanent record of
your scientific work so respond
completely respond politely and respond
with experimental data and that makes it
editors that makes reviewers and that
makes you also happy and that was my
last slide and thank you very much for
listening and my email address is here
Chandra
dot Milly poor comm if you like to
receive a free copy of our publication
introduction to antibodies and their
applications please send me an email and
respond back within the same day and
send you a copy thank you very much
thank you dr. Malan for that informative
presentation and we'll now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on that ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
questions into the box that appear on
the screen and click that send button
our speaker will follow up with your
questions via email so let's take a look
at some of our viewers questions dr. Mon
Western blotting is very commonly used
procedure for amino detection of
proteins but it's very time-consuming
can you give us any tips on how to save
time when performing Western blotting
this is a great question unfortunately
there are no shortcuts in the steps
involved however what we have done is we
have design in particular system we call
a snap ID system to streamline your
western blotting and
immunohistochemistry experiments the
concept is very simple here a vacuum
driven flow of blocking antibody and
washing solutions reduce slide and
membrane handling we use vacuum to
actively drive reagents through the
membrane that means a lot of less
shaking lot of a snipping boring waiting
etcetera are avoided and instead of
hours you can finish your multiple
slides or multiple plots within about 30
to 45 minutes also this technology
promotes antigen binding and thorough
washing enabling you to better optimize
your Western blotting applications our
Western blotting conditions so what you
can do is if you need more information
on snap ID just go to our website
iam developer.com and type in the word
snap s ma p and i dot d dot and you will
get a lot of information about this
particular system
thank you for that and sometimes a
review or may not understand all of the
complications and if I believe that my
data is good why not just knit to
another Journal who will publish it this
yes this can happen when submitting a
manuscript you can always say this one
or two names of scientists who are
experts in that field or you may even
indicate not to send to a particular
reviewer because you think that your
work conflicts with the other person and
then he may be biased in his opinion of
your manuscript so that you can always
do that you can always adjust names and
it is usually applied with that kind of
request it's important to consider that
a publication is a permanent record and
others will refer to your publication
for years to come
journals will select only knowledgeable
reviewers for you and others the quality
of publication is also important now
some time what happens you think that
the reviewer is asking too much work to
be done and at that time you decide that
you can send it to another general
sometimes the chances are that the same
reviewers who is an expert in that
particular field get your manuscript
again because of his or her expertise
and they will reject it again and even
be upset the best thing is design your
experiment well do the experiment well
and try to answer as many questions as
possible sometimes you want to put the
same data in two different publications
if you are going to do that tell the
reviewers tell the editors that you have
additional data if needed but you are
going to put it in two different
publications to make it manageable
great suggestions and dr. Mohan a viewer
wants to know are there any drawback in
designing knockout experiment with
performing antibody validations you know
knockout experiments and knockdowns are
very powerful negative controls but even
though they are very good controls and
very reliable but does not provide the
confirmation of binding also in some
cases the cell lines again a specific
gene may exhibit reduced viability
because that gene is important for
survival of this cell so what happens is
the you knock out that gene did cell may
not survive for too long yes we always
emphasize more than one validation
technique you can have a knockdown
experiment but also have at least one
more validation than on those samples
thank you and our final question is how
can we get a copy of your publication
introduction to antibodies and their
applications as I mentioned a little
while ago this is a very popular book
and we printed a lot of copies but
unfortunately we ran out of all of them
so it's currently out of print however
if you email me at chandra.harvard.edu a
PDF version the same day so please
remember that email address which I had
on the slide Chandra Mohan a TM TM
aleppo comm and let's send me an email
and I'll send you a PDF version same day
anyway thank you dr. Malan thank you
again for your presentation and thank
you for your important research I'd also
like to thank lab roots and our sponsor
Amelie poor Sigma for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through January 2019
you will receive an email from lab route
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's event that's
all for now and thank you for joining us
we hope to see you again soon bye bye